[Musique]
j'ai une histoire à vous raconter
l'histoire démarre en 1997 à Vouvray oui
l'équipe de super éducateurs à la
formidabilité de créer la ferme du petit
poseur une ferme d'animation dédiée aux
personnes fragilisées grâce à leur super
pouvoir
[Musique]
je disais grâce à leur super pouvoir ils
ont su s'entourer réunir des gens des
familles des établissements sociaux et
médico-sociaux aujourd'hui je vais alors
rencontre afin que il ou elle me raconte
leur formidable épopée allez c'est parti
la ferme du petit bonheur
bon alors pour commencer Kiki et vous
êtes où d'ailleurs Véronique présidente
Manu directrice rose coordinatrice
Aurélie animatrice
[Musique]
bon Manu on est où ici exactement alors
ici on est sur Tours Nord c'est un peu
nouveau pour nous nous sommes arrivés il
y a quelques jours on a donc déménagé on
avait une petite ferme sur Vouvray et on
a créé en 2004 avec les familles à 100
aéré pour enfants handicapés parce que
les familles ont besoin de moments de
répit et c'est vrai que les enfants
handicapés ne sont pas voire peu
accueillis dans les centres aérés donc
on l'a créé sur notre structure
bonjour les enfants on a qui là Monsieur
Oscar salut Oscar comment ça va viens
Hortense
[Musique]
Aurélia les enfants c'est vous les
patrons c'est votre émission à vous
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les animaux
vous voulez faire quoi on leur donne à
manger on leur donne à manger alors on
donne quoi à manger
ils sont là-bas
on leur donne à manger ensemble ou pas
voilà faites votre voilà c'est bien
super Aurélien c'est toi qui a adressé
comme ça les animaux là
ça marche c'est dingue c'est dingue on
va voir un peu les moutons ou pas allez
alors attendez
combien de temps déjà le lien avec les
animaux apporte beaucoup de sérénité et
puis d'attention aussi à l'autre on
essaye de travailler ça de faire
attention aux autres en passant par par
l'animal voilà
alors rencontre oui ici les chevaux
tu vas passer à la télé ah oui je te
jure on peut faire quoi comme activité
avec les chevaux les brosses très bien
on les brosse on les promène c'est bien
Oscar franchement tu fais ça très bien
apprends-moi comment on brosse je fais
comme toi je fais tout pareil je fais la
même chose que toi qu'est-ce que ça vous
apporte à vous les familles un peu le la
puissance de ce de cette structure
déjà du bien-être pour nos enfants
un peu de répit pour les parents aussi
il faut être honnête c'est ça aussi
c'est que c'est un espace où on sait que
nos enfants ils sont heureux dans un
cadre bienveillant les éducateurs et
éducatrices ici c'est comme c'est quand
même un peu des super-héros ah c'est
vrai super héroïne
[Musique]
vous l'avez compris le petit poseur ce
sont des gens qui ont le cœur sur la
main qui sont tournés vers les autres
c'est le vivre ensemble c'est l'amour
c'est le partage ce sont des vrais super
héros
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]